- Welcome back, y'all to our rad dad hour.
We've got an audience full of dads,
a studio full of penguins.
(audience clapping)
And Joel McHale hanging
out with us, y'all.
It's a good day.
It's a great day.
- [Joel] Yes.
- So you can see Joel
in Stargirl on the CW
and in Crime Scene Kitchen on Fox.
So I saw this message that you posted
on your son's 17th birthday.
- [Joel] Yes.
- So I'm, so here we go, I wanna show.
- Guys, this is my, uh, son.
This is a, oh, I've never
seen that guy in my life.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
Uh, no, uh that's Eddie on his 17th.
And uh, he's wearing my, uh, my
wife's dad's army trench coat.
And he's dressed like Morrissey, uh, from-
- [Kelly] I love it.
(Joel laughs)
No, but wait, I wanna read it.
- [Joel] From the 80's band.
- It's sweet though.
'Cause you said, I guess
you're not as much a boy now.
I love you and love the
young man you've grown into.
I love how in these shots
you look like you're
in a Smiths cover band.
- [Joel] Yes.
- [Kelly] (laughs) That's just awesome.
But it's sweet.
Is it freaking you out that
he is going into adulthood?
- Yeah, I bought him some cigarettes.
- (laughs) Oh, my god.
- And just, I'm kidding!
That is not a rad dad move
(Kelly laughs)
except for the one dad up in the corner.
Who's clapping.
He's very stressed out.
Yeah, It's very weird.
Your kids are little right.
- Five and seven.
- You, they still hug you?
- Oh, gosh, yeah.
My son, my five year
old, like is so excited.
Like a puppy when I get home still.
He, yeah.
- That's so great.
My, when I, now, whenever
I say I love you,
it's like Princess Leia and Han Solo
where I'm like, I love you.
And they're like, I know.
And then they walk away.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh, my God.
I don't want to get there.
- And they also say stuff
like dad, calm down.
And-
- Oh.
My seven year old daughter does that.
- My 13 year old, when
he gets outta the car,
I'll drop him off at school
and he'll go, see you,
dad, nobody loves you.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
And then-
- Oh, my gosh.
- And I, there's a side of me
that's so happy and so proud.
- They're very sarcastic,
then they're like you.
- They are, yeah.
- You only have yourself
to blame for their sense of humor.
- No, I blame my own father.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
(Kelly clapping)
- [Kelly] Like all good people in therapy.
- Yeah.
- So wait, what was your favorite
don't tell mom moment with your boys?
- I have a secret family in Missouri.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
And I'm like, don't tell mom.
- Is that weird?
- We're visiting my friend again.
- Oh, my God.
- Oh, those other people
that kind of look like you,
ah, don't worry about it.
(Kelly babbles)
Kansas City chase.
- Don't get on ancestry.com.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Joel] Yeah.
I don't, uh, boy.
See, my dad used to be like,
should we go to Baskin and Robbins again?
And we're like, that's fine.
But it was really just for him.
And-
- Oh, yeah.
- My mom would be like, how many?
And she'd see all the wrappers all
over his car and be like,
(laughs) the kids wanted to go again and-
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh, my God.
- He, we-
- [Kelly] You've totally used
your kids though for something, right?
To be like, yeah, they wanted to do it.
But really it was you.
- Yeah, usually to get 'em into rides
at Disneyland or something.
I'm a little like, he has
to go to the bathroom.
We need to go to the head of the line.
And, uh,
(Kelly laughs)
so, but, yeah, I don't know.
(stammers) Yeah, but keeping, ugh,
my wife- She'll, I can't get
anything by her. So, she-
- [Kelly] She got eyes everywhere?
- She's way smarter.
- And-
- Yeah, I'm not
good at secrets I hate, I
literally tell my friends
and my kids, I'm like, don't tell me
if you want me to keep a secret,
I'm not, I feel-
- It will come out a song.
(Kelly stammers)
Own it, you'll sing it.
- No, it'll come out within
minutes and I'll just be like,
and wasn't supposed to say this, but like,
I get freaked out.
I don't like secrets.
- That's pretty great.
- I tell all my friends and be like,
don't tell me anything.
Like, that you don't
want everyone to know.
- That's a great friendship.
- No, because, no, here's why.
I mean, if it's something,
like, really serious, like
maybe I wouldn't but I just
- Right, right.
- But I don't like secrecy.
It, it, it freaks me.
- Right.
- I'm sweating right now. Thinking
about it.
- Just thinking about
- Just thinking about it,
I don't like secrets. Yeah.
- I'll be like, my wife will be like
you can get a couple
donuts, but don't get them
two a piece and then I'll get
six and I'll be like
(Kelly and audience laughing)
they just gave them to me.
(audience laughing)
I can't-
- Yeah
- They're big fans.
- People love me.
- They love Crime Scene Kitchen,
Stargirl so yeah.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Love that!
- And yeah.
- And then I'll eat three.
- Oh!
- Then I'll feel guilty.
- 'Cause they're good!
- Yeah.
- I don't feel guilty about that.
- So wait we need another break everybody,
but first tell us-
- I'm fine, We can keep going.
- [Kelly] No, no. Tell us-
- No, the rad dads are happy-
- Before we go to break.
I wanna hear what you're doing.
'Cause you always have so
many jobs. You're always doing
so many things
- That's true. I really do.
- You're so popular, Joel.
- Thanks for saying it.
Oh, I'm on a show called Stargirl
that's on HBO.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah.
- Max and CW.
And I played Starman that
Luke Wilson,
Brec Bassinger
and Amy smart are in it to name a few.
And then I host a baking show
on Fox.
- [Kelly] I love that you
- get to be in the kitchen.
- Yeah.
- Yeah I love the baking show.
- There it is.
- Yeah.
(audience clappinG)
- There's Yolanda.
- That's with Curtis Stone
and Yolanda Gampp and we have
it's a competition baking show.
I'm hosting the Kelly Clarkson show
(Kelly laughing)
for the next two years.
I don't know if you know this
- I love it. I'm in.
- And then I host a thing
called Celebrity Beef
which is another cooking show.
(audience cheering)
- I love it.
- So yeah. I-
- You like to be in the kitchen.
- I love being in the kitchen.
- Yeah.
- And I don't say no to anything.
- And I know
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- I mean, look at this haircut.
- I like your Hair!
- Oh, thank you.
- Yeah!
- I'm a big fan of Peaky Blinders.
(audience and Kelly laughing)
- Oh my God. All right.
Joel's done a great job raising his kids
but how good is he?
- We'll see.
- We'll see. But how good is he
at helping other dads raise theirs?
- [Joel] Terrible.
- We will find out next.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah
(clapping)
- [Kelly] This is killing me.